what's going on everybody welcome to the
13th Monte Carlo in Python tutorial
video in the last video we set up this
day Alan Barrett strategy we found that
we were having quite a bit of loss but
that's most likely because we're not
actually playing 50/50 odds here so the
next thing I want to do is go ahead and
make a new roll dice function and this
one will be real 5050 odds so let's just
copy this come down here paste get rid
of this and now instead if roll is less
than or equal to 50 great and then if
role is if roll is greater than or equal
to 51 any win so now we have real 5050
odds so first of all let us test this
strategy one like I you bastard yep okay
and let's oh my goodness we're printing
everything out okay I'm gonna move that
over there while I shut up everything
else and so what we'll do then instead
of doing let's do a thousand wagers and
we'll go back to wager size of 100 still
Kevin me fine there our users are ending
let's see 10 400
it appears to me that our math math is
all correct so we'll continue on and
we'll keep doing what I wanted to get us
to anyway so maybe we'll find what's
wrong later if anything is even wrong so
now the odds are 50/50 let us go ahead
and and it's some stuff up here at least
sample size well I guess we leave that
at a thousand starting funds ten
thousand wagers I will put the starting
funds to a hundred thousand wager sizes
a hundred wager count is a thousand it's
for kicks
okay at least somebody finally made some
money let's try again and we've got
losers but then we've got some winners
okay so that makes me a little happier
clearly a 100 was a little bit too large
I believe the number is if you were
gonna bet a $1 each time you really
would need to start with like 1.6
million dollars to like for sure not get
yourself screwed so just keep that in
mind so obviously with this strategy you
do need to you have to be able to be in
it for the long haul so yeah anyway
continuing on now that we've done this
we want to know on a grand scale how
good is the Dalembert strategy really so
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to come down to this day Alan Bear
strategy and we want to have one I have
another variable so the Alan bear
strategy we're gonna have global I want
to use return but I know I can't one of
you is like return ROI isn't the right
word cuz it's not a return on investment
I want to know like what is our return
yes we could say with global ret for for
return and then all the way down here
well we printed out value we'll just say
plus equals value and so now what we
want to do is we'll keep da and this
will get rid of this and we'll take this
unless traverse all the way down to
where we have this and we'll paste that
right there
and don't forget Brett point zero save
where we are so now what I want to do is
have a sample a large amount of this day
Alan Bear strategy because as I said
before profit and bust isn't really the
most telling because we want to know
obviously if people don't profit we want
to know how badly do they lose and then
of the people who profit how good do
they profit because if the profit is
good enough then it's still a good
enough gamble to take right so if you
stand to lose ten thousand but you stand
to gain five hundred thousand and then
odds are 50/50 then you might as well
play a few times and you'll do well so
with that we'll say da profits da bust
and we also needed we'll do a samp size
and this is how many vertebra as you do
we want we'll start with a hundred
thousand now I'm gonna go ahead and just
delete all of this and really we'll just
get rid of everything mmm and what we're
gonna do now is we're gonna say counter
equals one Wow
counter is less than or equal to duh
samp sighs what do we want to do well
we're gonna run de allen bear that's for
sure
and we're also gonna go counter plus
equals one now at the end of it if we've
done everything correct we're gonna say
print
total invested and total investment is
gonna be dust samp sighs times starting
funds so the same size how many people
times how many funds they start with and
that gives you how much total money was
invested now we're gonna say print total
return ret capital R now we want to know
what's the difference difference or
actually now we can use our ROI and
that's going to be ret - this so
copy-paste and don't really care much
about the bus rate and all that but
we'll we'll do it anyway
bus rate is MDA underscore busts divided
by duck Sam sighs times 100 point zero
zero and I'm just gonna copy this and
we'll remember to edit our variable in a
second but print profit rate and da
profits okay cool so actually to start
let's just do a small sample of a
hundred just to run everything and see
if we're oh my goodness we don't want to
print let me shut up the printing of
value here okay but I'll still show you
guys the UH the outcome here so we do
see that a few people did go broke
clearly but scrolling down we can see on
a long-term scale we had this much
invested so what is this looks like ten
million invested from ten million a
profit of two hundred and forty four
thousand is returned not bad
bust rate was 19 and a profit percent
was 68 so that's the outcome there not a
bad outcome
truly I don't think that's a
representative amount though to be quite
honest so let's run a larger amount now
that we're confident and processing time
isn't gonna take 14 years
let's do 100,000 yeah I guess we'll do a
hundred thousand this might take a
really long time I don't think I'm
pretty anything until the end now so I
put it here I'll pause while this is
running that way not everybody has to do
this if you want feel free to do it and
pause the video as well until you're
done all right here we go with a this
was a hundred thousand sample size as we
can see with a hundred thousand sample
size we actually had a loss not a large
loss that's a big number but not on the
scale of this number but we did actually
incur a loss so there are a couple
reasons why that could be first of all
the wager size is still a little bit too
big for the starting funds in the wager
count there's not necessarily a reason
we just have to say stop at some point
for a wager count but it might be you
beneficial to allow up to you know ten
thousand wager or something like that
and then let's say with a hundred I
kinda want to leave that and we'll let
the wagers go well I say we let the
wagers go all the way to one hundred
thousand really but I do think our wager
size is too big for that but that's okay
so we'll do that and now we'll come down
here and instead of a hundred thousand
it's not really a large sample size
we'll do a sample size of a million and
again I'll run this the previous test
took quite a while so I expect this will
take probably like I don't even know
probably an hour all honesty that's a
big big one so anyway I'll run this and
I'll just pause it while I run it and
after that I'll just show the image of
it and say my my goodbyes so anyways
that's gonna conclude this video
hopefully you guys enjoyed as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscription
until next time